very pleased to say the health secretary
matt hancock uh joins us once again
on the program minister great to see you
this morning and look
we are all in need of a bit of a
pick-me-up these days so but let's start
with
with the good news and there really is
some good news around this morning the
information
released yesterday about the efficacy of
the oxford vaccine combined with that
research
uh from uk biobank today about about
antibodies i mean taken all together
does this mean uh mr hancock that you
and i are going to be enjoying our
summer holiday this year
not together i should point out
well who knows i i very much hope so uh
this oxford report is
a very good news uh it backs the
strategy that we've taken and it shows
the world
that the oxford vaccine works
effectively
and the really good news embedded in it
is that it not
just reduces hospitalizations there were
no people in this part of the trial who
were hospitalized with covid
after getting the oxford jab but also it
reduces
the number of people who have covert at
all even
asymptomatically by around
two-thirds and so that reduction
in transmission as well as the
uh very very you know the fact there's
no hospitalizations
uh the combination of that is very good
news
and it categorically supports the
strategy that we've been taking
of having a 12-week gap between the
doses
because it shows that the strength of
the protection you get
is uh is in fact slightly enhanced by a
12-week gap between the doses so it's
it's good news all around
good news and indeed and taken together
let's just reflect for a moment on
on the antibody research the the fact
that you could possess
some level of natural immunity if you've
had covered 19 for as much as six months
again i'm being slightly cheeky and
referring to the
to the summer holiday that everyone so
desperately wants but
all of this taken together it does feel
like we we might be moving in the
direction
of being able to plan that far ahead
well there's the vaccine has always been
the way out of this and
you know we back them from the start
because they can give that immunity
without having to have the disease so
yes of course the uh the existence of uh
antibodies for
six months after you've had the disease
is good protection for people like
like me who've who've had it but of
course we want people to get protection
without
having to have the disease and that's
what the vaccines are all about
there's one other thing that's really
important in this which is that
we linked up this vaccine trial with
the testing system to ensure
that you could test people every week
after they'd have the had the vaccine or
the placebo in the trial
that's why we know that the
oxford vaccine reduces your
likelihood of getting covered whether
symptomatic or not and it's the only
trial
that has made that test and made that
link
because we linked it to nhs tests and
trace from the start of the
of the trial so you know this shows
british science
working extremely well linked up with
the
uh with the nhs and the government
effort um
and it means that people right around
the world could be confident
in this oxford vaccine and i'm very very
pleased about that
what though of the of the pfizer vaccine
particularly as regards the south
african variant
um vlad tests in cambridge suggesting
that that one only has
enough protection after a second dose
that that will be of concern presumably
given
uh that we have been rolling out fires
are here
well the the fact that there is some
protection from the
uh from the variant in first found in
south africa
um that itself is good news uh there was
a fear that the vaccines wouldn't work
at all against that bearing
whereas there does appear to be some
protection
but there is a need in the in the
research it does suggest that you do
need that second dose
to kind of approach the levels of
efficacy that we want to see
well of course against these new
variants we may well need
boosters that have a slightly adjusted
vaccine
as well in the same way that we do for
flu each year
and we're working with the companies on
on that on developing those and then
ensuring that they can get regulated and
they can be safely used much more
quickly than first time around because
they're
it's just a it's an adjustment to the
vaccine rather than a completely new
vaccine
like these ones so that is an important
piece of work
but the core piece of work is to
vaccinate people against the
virus that is at large right across the
country now
of course that we need to protect people
from
still though there will be people who
are concerned this morning when they
wake up and and read the news that the
kent radiant the british the homegrown
variant does appear to have
acquired that that e48 4k
uh mutation um which redu so
in essence we have a variant in the
country at the moment that has both
increased transmissibility and greater
resistance to the vaccine i mean
should we be concerned about that well
we've seen a very small number of cases
of this uh
this new mutation of concern but it is
absolutely critical that where we find
them
we absolutely stamp on it and
the actions that we've taken to put in
the enhanced contact tracing the extra
testing in the whole community around
where we find a case
and the clear instructions to people in
those areas
that it is imperative that they stay at
home and avoid
all contact with other people outside
their household
wherever possible that is important you
know in a national lockdown
we will be able to uh to
to tackle this but it is it does require
as all social distancing
requires it it it requires a team effort
from all of us it does it does and but
just
just on that point on the the team
effort because of course it involves the
public but it also involves the
government be it local or be it national
in terms of the financial support i mean
we're asking people in places like
walking to
not go out to the shops you know in
essence if you've got food in the
cupboards
as things stand 70 of people who are
applying for financial help
to self-isolate have been denied it one
in four
in fact in one in four council areas
that figure rises to to 90
of all applications being rejected what
is going on here i mean it strikes me as
one of two options
either you know the english public is
committing fraud in a massive scale
or the systems knackered and it just
doesn't work
no neither of those are true what's
happening is that we're targeting the
support of those who need it most
so we've got a clear eligibility for the
500 pounds payment
and if you are in receipt of uh of
benefits because you're low paid
uh then you will be able to get that
support and
the so we should expect to see figures
of 70 rejection
in local authorities that that was kind
of within your modeling that's
that's what you expected to see well it
depends who's supplying neil and and
but i know what's working because i've
obviously looked into this and
local councils are making the decision
to ensure that it is
that those who are low-paid who get the
support
and making sure that we target support
to the right places
has always been a very important part of
any government's plan to support people
so um the financial support is there
the testing is there in very large scale
and crucially because we built this this
big
genomic sequencing capability we can
spot new variants and we can
then you know take the action that's
needed can we talk
for a moment about the measures that are
being taken uh being taken at our
borders
and sage advised the government about a
couple of weeks ago that if we wanted
to come as close as possible to removing
the risk of new variants arriving here
in the uk there are two things you could
do
close the borders or or mandatory
quarantine the government
did not choose to do that can you
explain
why the government didn't didn't follow
that particular piece of advice
well again you've got that wrong i'm
afraid um the government brought in
mandatory self-isolation for every
passenger coming into this country
we used to as you'll remember last
summer we used to have
the travel corridors so some countries
you could travel to travel back from
and not have to isolate we changed the
law
and now you have to isolate wherever
you've come from
now of course we're looking always to
strengthen protections further
but we brought in those protections on
the basis of
of this advice yeah 10 000 people
roughly perhaps
are arriving here in the uk every day
through our airports it was a week ago
that we were first told that quarantine
hotels were on the way
when are we going to have them well
obviously we're working on these
proposals that's specifically from
redless countries
and and the red and the you're not at
the moment allowed to travel direct from
redless countries
at all so but the key word there the key
word is direct there wasn't to health
secretary i had a quick look online this
morning if i want to
fly from johannesburg to london cost me
300 pounds
i can do it today and i fly via doha
and you have to isolate and
that is a legal requirement and we have
enhanced enforcement
against that so i think that i of course
we're always looking to strengthen these
things but we already have very
stringent measures in place at the
border
you say that we have very stringent
measures in place in the border as
things stand
we've spoken to border force we've
spoken to the union representing them on
this program before
as things stand by their reckless you
know all you need to do
is have a fairly professional bit of
paper in your hand saying i have tested
negative
for covert 19 within the past 72 hours
and in terms of you know self-isolation
yep great many people will do it
a lot of others won't well it is a
criminal offence to lie
to the border force and so
you know it cha it's always a challenge
in
in government to ensure compliance with
the uh with the rules and the
the truth is there is stringent measures
in place at the border
there are it's a criminal offence if you
do exactly what you just uh described
sure um however we are also
looking to strengthen measures in
particular from those countries that
have that
highest risk and uh work is underway to
uh to develop that so you know
protecting people
with strong action at the border is
absolutely
necessary so too is the
lockdown at home unfortunately to
to make sure we get this virus under
control sure but good news
is we can see our path out and the data
that we've
had published that we've seen published
last night reinforces the fact that
the the strategy that we're taking is
the right one to get us out of this
safely but the health sector just as
things stand
with the controls that we have at the
border with
with no date and there was no date from
you as to when those quarantine hotels
will be in place isn't it the case that
there is a possibility
that a new potentially dangerous variant
could arrive here
in the united kingdom bypassing all of
the security that you've just mentioned
well of course in a country that like uh
britain
making sure that we protect at the
border
is always a challenge but is important
and hence we've put in place the very
stringent measures that we've got
and we're putting in place further
measures but but
i sorry to repeat the question but but
no one i'm i'm not asking for a
guarantee because no one can guarantee
but absent those measures that sage
recommended
no mandatory quarantine or just a
closing but the thing is
the reason this is a slightly um odd uh
exchange is that
you keep reading out that sage wanted
mandatory
uh uh isolation for those who have
arrived
and that's what we've got now i'm up for
strengthening that
further and we're looking at that uh but
you
you know we do work very closely with
these scientists and
uh they are they are brilliant at
working in with uncertainty because
you know epidemiology is a and is an
uncertain science and there's a lot of
when will we have the hotels when will
we have the quarantine hotels
uh well that'll be set out shortly but
the critical thing is
the measures are already in place to
require
the isolation of every single passenger
who comes into this country
now further enforcement of that of
course
can always be introduced and
strengthened
but the but the advice is clear that
people everybody coming in should
isolate
and the we removed the travel corridors
where there was no isolation so you know
this
idea that you're trying to um propose
that there hasn't been action on the
border is completely wrong
i'm certainly not doing that minister
but thanks for your time this morning